voicemail we have a voicemail number
that number is two one nine two david p
we have had this back and forth
controversy involving Pat's cat and it
being an outdoor cat which angered some
people because outdoors outdoor cats
kill migratory birds supposedly although
I haven't independently research that a
fewer named Steve Eggman
you might recognize their voice but they
go by the name Steve Eggman they called
in and they love what Pat is doing with
his cat take a listen to this hi this is
Steve Eggman calling for pat pat I have
a couple of tests I love them very much
I know they love me
I left them outside and they killed tons
of stuff Birds little critters voles
moles Chipmunks they're murdering
machines anything they kill didn't
deserve to be alive in the first place
they're just doing their job in nature
good for the cats have a good day guys
Shalom all right so the Eggman clearly
this is Steve Eggman or the Eggman as
we've known him for many years he says
that it's natural its nature that hey if
you put a cat outside which is a cat
which is where a cat naturally goes that
it's going to kill things and it's not
you who would be blamed for that this is
the circle of life yeah well you know I
mean so much focus has been on me and my
CNN over the past few months I think the
clear scandal here is that Eggman knows
that his cats kill so many of these
rodents and birds and yet he just
continues to let them outside to the
best of my knowledge Miss Muffet my cat
does not kill too many of these but you
know the really great news is Keurig
scandal no but nobody even remembers the
Keurig scandal because this new
migratory bird outdoor cat situation is
completely made everybody forget about
that that I think you can be glad if
right yeah that's good on the bonus show
today there is a nearby star which is a
good model of an earlier version of our
solar system okay we're going to talk
about that on the bonus show we're also
going to talk about the SpaceX plans
SpaceX of course one of Ilan Musk's
companies to launch broadband satellites
in 2019
which will if we believe this is going
to happen deliver gigabit speeds also
and this is not a fun story at all there
has been a horrible horrible murder in
my neighborhood in Boston and well I
won't even get into it now we'll talk
about the details on the bonus show
david pakman.com slash membership is how
you sign up for the bonus show
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can pledge a dollar or two towards our
production and you can also get on our
mailing list at david pakman.com Friday
we are going to have a mass email go out
to everybody on our newsletter with a
huge coupon code okay major major coupon
code for a discount off of membership
all you've got to do is get on our
newsletter at david pakman.com